Sh.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
foreign
[Silence]
speech. foreign.
Subhan Allah.
forch.
[Silence]
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
Forch.
[Silence]
for
Here
[Silence]
we have a narration
which has been collected by
regarding the virtues of knowledge.
Again we are in the chapter and the book
of knowledge of the 12th book. Do we
remember how many books are in
19 books in
book number 12 is the book of knowledge
regarding the virtues of knowledge. He
mentions a narration on the authority of
Abu narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said
the
dunya and the word dunya comes from adun
and adun means that which is closest to
us. So it's referred to as the life of
the dunya meaning the closer of the two
lives to us currently.
He says that the
it is
and everything in it is
now what does that mean? Does that mean
it is cursed?
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa tala
And so, What does the word mean?
Sometimes this will be translated
incorrectly
as the dunya is cursed
along with everything in it.
In the Quran when Allah mentions
Allah
this is translated roughly to being
damned. And what is damned?
is that something is removed from the
mercy of Allah. That's what is. We say
that for instance, who is someone who is
in the Quran?
The chief tin of the in the Quran.
he saysl,
which is interesting, right? Because and
are kind of two sides of the same
coin, right?
L is the
jin version and
is the human version essentially. But
yeah, both of them they are melon.
So what does this mean? This means that
they are damned. What is the result of
being damned? You are exempted.
The damned person is exempted from the
mercy of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. They
have been removed from the mercy of
Allah. Not eligible to receive mercy
from Allah.
But is that what the dunya is? It is all
exempted from the mercy of Allah. No.
Allah tells us that he has created
everything and everything is created
into the mercy of Allah. Correct? Right.
So what's meant here is linguistically
in the language of the Arabs
is something that is
something that is tending to decay,
something that is tending to be
become nothing that is dwindling away
and something that is inconsequential
and something that is distant
from the highest levels of of
attributes. This is referred to as
linguistically and that's what's
intended here.
Doesn't mean everything and everybody is
is created in this dunya into the
damnation of Allah. That is the belief
of modern Christianity, the original
sin. Correct? By default, we're all in
the red.
And then we have to have a savior come
and get us out of the red into the
black. That is not the belief of the
Muslim. That is not something that was
taught to them by Isaam. The human being
is created into innocence. And then we
proceed to write in our books what we
choose. Correct?
And so
what's this narration is saying is that
everything in the dunya
is tending towards decay
is tending towards
becoming inconsequential to becoming
a distant memory. Everything is bound to
this decay and everything hence is
distant from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
except
there's an exception. What is the
exception? He tells us
four things.
He says everything in the dunya is
distant from Allah. Everything in the
dunya is to decay. Everything in the
dunya is to
whittle away and pine away into
nothingness. Everything in the dunya is
bound to oblivion
except for four things.
This narration is meant to be taken
literally. Only these four things
remain. What are they? The remembrance
of Allah, the obedience of Allah,
the scholar and the student, the scholar
of the knowledge of Allah of the Quran
and Sunnah. That's what the whole
chapter is about.
and his student. That is it.
Only
thing that will remain when your death
comes for you, when your death comes for
you, when your numbers pulled, when my
numbers pulled, when your numbers are
pulled,
when your soul is extracted,
what comes out with your soul? These
four things. That's it. Nothing else.
You're a physicist, you're a doctor,
you're a brilliant
lit you know a brilliant teacher
of literature, whatever it is, these are
issues of the dunya. You will leave them
behind and you will shed them with your
physical form. They are no longer of use
to you.
The only thing that will be
consequential of these things is what
you did with them that fit into these
four categories.
This is where does the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam get this? I mean
obviously
correct. So everything he says is part
of the revelation
but most of what he says or much of what
he says comes from what he understood
from the Quran.
What is a chapter or a verse of the
Quran that every one of us memorized
right now that says this exact same
thing?
[Arabic recitation]
But that doesn't mention
you said
I'm mentioning you last cuz you got it
right. Yes.
Insan,
[Silence]
it all goes back in the box.
Look at the ground that's underneath
your feet. You know, on this same right
here, this exact spot
a thousand years ago, 500 years ago, 200
years ago, a completely different people
stood right here, made proclamations of
eternity, and now where are they? We
don't even know their names. They would
kill you over this piece of land.
They're not here anymore to fight for
that land. and it's gone. We don't even
know their names. That's how little they
have to do with this piece of land that
they bled on.
What do you think is going to happen to
us? Or are we special?
Maybe we're special. Maybe we're the
special ones. We're the chosen ones to
be here forever. Maybe our strain and
struggle for life will be different than
the thousands of generations that
preceded us.
That's something you're going to have to
roll the dice on. Proverb the proverbial
dice. Are you special or are you fitting
into the pattern?
[Silence]
That's it. Everything else goes back in
the box. Everything.
We to think that we're very
important and we are in a sense. It's
how we make ourselves important. We like
to think that I to think that my
son will never say dad to anyone else.
I to think that my wife would never
in a million years marry again.
I to think that my car is mine and
my sofa is mine and my stuff is mine,
that my money is mine. But you know
what? It's not.
And if your wife gets lonely enough,
she'll marry again. And if your son is
taken care of enough, he'll call someone
else father in a general way, in a
respectful way.
None of us is beyond being replaced.
What makes us irreplaceable? Our
relationship with Allah. That is the
only thing that is unique about us.
Everything else has been done better,
more thoroughly, and longer. than
anything we're going to do. That's just
the reality of our existence. Now, that
could be a good thing or it could be a
very bad thing. I find it to be very
liberating
that I'm not bound to this rat race.
That my struggle is special with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. That in spite of
humanity overlooking my pain, every
moment of my pain is charted with Allah.
and I'll be recompensed for it. And that
no one before me or after me has the
exact same relationship with Allah that
I have. I find that to be a great relief
and
for
[Silence]
being a Muhammad.